I want to thank everybody this has been
some period of time and most importantly
we want to thank the great people of
Iowa thank you we love you all Trump won
last night he is going to be the nominee
I don't really see any way around it
there's no sense of me bullsh now I
probably you know I've had a lot of
trump people pissed at me over the last
year now I probably have some hardcore
disantis people pissed at me but I but I
have to just tell you what I think it's
a simple as that here is some of Trump's
uh acceptance speech when well not
acceptance didn't accept anything here
is his uh hey I won tonight's speech
well I want to thank everybody this has
been some period of time and most
importantly we want to thank the great
people of Iowa thank you we love you all
what a turnout what a crowd and I really
think this is time now for everybody our
country to come together we want to come
together uh whether it's republican or
democrat or liberal or conservative it
would be so nice if we could could come
together and straighten out the world
and straighten out the problems and
straighten out all of the death and
destruction that we're witnessing that's
practically never been like this it's
just so important and I want to make
that a very big part of our message
we're going to come together it's going
to happen soon too going to happen
soon okay I don't know if we're going to
come together Democrat and Republican
come together liberal and conservative
come together uh but those of us who
lean right let's say or Cent
to a bit right we should come together
right now and I think if if he goes with
that message right and now tries to fill
in the pieces okay okay Ron I yeah I
kind of lied about Co in Florida and
yeah you had nothing to do with Soros or
Paul Ryan or whatever like we'll bring
you back into the fold and be you know I
hit you at the end there but you know
you're young and you've got something
then we can start building a coalition
that will make sense I don't think we're
going to have like like sort of this
like um shangrala of peace right like I
don't think we're just going to be like
all the Democrats are gonna be like oh
Donald Trump's saying nice things this
is all wonderful like maybe you say
Nikki you know what you're not a birdb
brain I I mean I think it's very likely
he will end up choosing her as VP but we
could get some roughly United group of
people that believe in freedom and
liberty together right now and then
again the challenge for some of us that
were en thrilled with Trump this time
will be to push him in the right way not
to bow not to bow I have no intentions
of doing that uh but if we're just like
all right he is the guy the reason I
supported him last time around after not
supporting him the first time is because
he became a good president he was Sid
Tred by covid and he screwed up a whole
bunch of stuff but we all know the
country was in better shape and the
world was in better shape while he was
President uh so I think his speech right
there the Come Together part which was
the that was the main heart of the
speech
I think was a pretty good indicator
hopefully of what a campaign might look
like